[Applaudissements]
2e 2e défi c'est contre jean-michel bear
ou là on va appeler quelqu'un au hasard
au téléphone et vous allez dire à la
personne beau jour je suis jean michel
meyer ce que voulait prendre un verre
aller pour voir ce que va répondre la
personne qui va faire la même chose
d'après noël c'est légal je parle
y aller on avance quoi partez quoi gagne
on avance musée blanc ah oui bien sûr de
perdre
oui vous avez un physique magnifique
pareil non mais c'est vrai nous voit
dégueulasse et de placer le télétravail
c'est parti on a peine à croire débat on
l'appelle tout on y va et juste après il
y aura une nouvelle danse c'est parti on
appelle quelqu'un du smic vous dit juste
je suis jean michel maire voulait
prendre avec moi c'est au hasard
complètement allô allô bonjour oui
bonjour vous appelez comment juliette
jarju net je vais aller droit au but
on va c'est jean michel maire ne touche
pas à mon poste et je voulais savoir si
[Applaudissements]
je vous jure je vous jure que ça l'ait
pas truqué je vous le seul vraiment je
peux vous le jurer perçu êtes vous
n'étiez pas condamné aux appelé ses
céréales énervé qui c'est cyril hanouna
et tpm et oui bien sûr gpmb hanouna le
pakistanais oui
ba et ba jean michel d'astous voulait
aller prendre un verre avec lui
[Applaudissements]
la même chose avec hadji maintenant